عبر التاريخ والازمان قصص وحكايات من
مختلف البلدان والحضارات توارثتها الاجيال
وتروجها شعوب العالم على انها حقيقه اخرون
يعتبرونها ضربا من الخيال والخرافات وفي
عصرنا الحديث هناك من يصدقها ويعتبر
اللعنه عقابا بديلا عن القانون وحتى عالم
الرياضه لا يخلو من هذه الكلمه وابسطها
لعنه الاصابه وفي ارض الفراعنه وبحسب
مؤرخين لم تكن اللعنات لدى المصريين
القدماء نابعه عن حقد بل كانت وسيله
دفاعيه فهما اعتقدوا ان الجسد والروح
متلازمان وان الجسد يجب الا يبلى لكي لا
تفنى الروح بهذا السبب احاطوا مراقدهم
ومدافنهم بمختلف عبارات اللعن والتخويف من
المصير المظلم لكل من تطوع له نفس
الاقتراب من الموتى سمر بشات خاضت تجربه
للكشف عن سر وحقيقه لعنه الفراعنه بحثت من
داخل اشهر مواقع اللعنات الاسطوريه والت
اريخيه قبر الملك توت عنخ امون المزيد في
هذا التقرير نتابع
لعنه الفراعنه العالم الغامض عند قدماء
المصريين اهي حقيقه ام اسطوره
نصوص كتبت على جدران المقابر لمنع اللصوص
يعتقد انها تسببت في احداث ماساويه
لمكتشفيها
اسرار وقصص عن عالم السحر وما يعرف بالعنه
الفراعنه دفنت مع اصحابها منذ الاف السنين
اثارت فضول العلماء انبهر بها الاعلام
وتناولتها السينما المصريه والعالميه
دفعنا الفضول للبحث في اصل هذه الحكايه
وحقيقتها فذهبنا لنمسك ببدايه الخيط مقبره
توت عنخ امون بوادي الملوك بمدينه الاقصر
[موسيقى]
اشهر تلك الاساطير كانت هنا مع فتح مقبره
توت عنخ امون القرن الماضي احداث غامضه
طالت افراد البعثه ما حير العالم لسنوات
طويله فلنكتشف حكايه هذه المقبره وسر هذا
اللغز
ففي عام
1922 عثر عالم الاثار البريطاني هاورث
كارتر على اكبر كشف اثري حتى ذلك الوقت
مقبره الملك الصغير توت عنخ امون اول
مقبره تكتشف كامله لم تصل اليها ايادي
لصوص المقابر وبعد سته اشهر من اكتشاف
المقبره توفي ممول كشف اللورد كرنفون في
مصر متاثرا بلدغه بعوضه
وهو داخل فندق شيبرد في القاهره
وروحوا بتطلع حاجتين حصلوا النور بيفطي
واعلى وقام الكلب بتاعه في نفس الوقت مات
في قلعته في انجلترا طبعا بص في الكلام
هتلاقي سنه 22 الكهرباء في مصر وطالع على
طول نمره اتنين ازاي
عشان تطلبي في الوقت ده ممكن تقعدي اسبوع
او شهر على ما يردوا عليك
وفي السنوات القليله التاليه للكشف توفي
عدد من الذين كانت لهم علاقه مباشره او
غير مباشره بالمقبره ومنهم عالم مصريات
كان يعمل مع كارتر مات قبل انهاء عمله ما
عزز من الاعتقاد بوجود لعنه حقيقيه ليه
حصلت لعنه الفراعنه لان اللي هو ممول هذه
المقبره ادى الحق الحصري لنشر الاخبار عن
هذا اكتشاف العظيم لجرنان انجليزي واحد
اللي هو التايمز البريطانيه فده خلى كل
الصحفيين التانيين سواء من انجلترا او
خارجها يفتعلوا قصص عن لعنه الفراعنه وده
اللي خلى هذا التيرم وهذا المصطلح
يظهر منذ ذلك الحين
[موسيقى]
ومنذ ذلك الحين اطلقت عباره لعنه الفراعنه
على عده احداث غامضه وايضا اساطير ومنها
وجود مومياء على متن سفينه تايتنك قبل
غرقها في بدايه القرن الماضي واحد خبير
امريكاني
جايب بوميه فكان هيجيبها على الباخره فبدل
ما يجيبها على الباخره اداها هديه الى
المتحف فالميه لمطرحتش على الباخره اطلاقا
[موسيقى]
مقبره بيتي تقع بالقرب من اهرامات الجيزه
وهي احدى مقابر العمال بنات الاهرامات على
جدران هذه المقبره كتبت نصوص تحذيريه تحذر
كل من يعبث بالمقبره او صاحبها
[موسيقى]
المصري القديم لما كان بيسيب نص اللعنه
على المقبره
هتطلع على مقبره بيقول اسمعوا ايها الناس
انني لم افعل شيئا سيئا في حياتي وكل ما
فعلته كان صحيحا ولذلك احبتني الالهه وكل
من هيمس مخبرتي هتاكلوا التماسيح وفرس
النهر والاسود اعتقاد الفراعنه في البعث
والخلود وايمانهم الشديد بان المتوفى
سيحيا من جديد ليعيش حياه ابديه كان سببا
في استخدامهم للسحر ونصوص اللعنه وان كان
معظم علماء الاثار ينفون وجود تاثير لها
ما هي حقيقه لعب فرع
لو قفلت الاوضه دي اللي احنا فيها 3000
سنه جوه هذه الحجره مومياء او بودع عضويه
بتطلع جراثيم غير مرئيه المومياء كلها
حاجات تتعفن بتطلع جراثيم علماء الاثار
زمان يقوموا داخلين بسرعه الجراثيم تقرصهم
يموتوا انا بعمل ايه دلوقتي بقوم فاتح
المقبره يوم او ساعتين او تلاته لما الهوا
الفاسق يطلع والهوى النقي يدخل وما فيش
حاجه
[موسيقى]
سمر باشات لصباح العربيه من القاهره
انا بدي احكي لكم سر على سيره لعنه
الفراعنه انه سهام العزيزه قليل لتنزل صور
على السوشيال ميديا فانت اذا بتنزلي صوره
اكيد راح نتذكرها تمام انا متذكره انه انت
من سنه تقريبا او من سنتين من سنتين للدقه
نزلت صوره بال يعني قبر بالكرامات هل انت
بتعتقدي انه في لعنه حلت عليك
وهي اللي اصرت ننزل على فكره كان السلم
لتنزلي تحت بالهرم للقبر تحت اوكي يعني
المساحه الضيقه جدا وتحت الاكسجين ما في
يعني قلنا بنعاني بس اللعنه ما لعنا والله
الله اعلم بس انا كمان بدي اقول لك على
سيره اللعنات انا من حيه سمر بشات على
التقرير فعلا تقرير رائع ومعمول باحكام
وموضوع جدا جميل يعني ما زالت لعنه
الفراعنه تحير العلماء حتى الان بس انا
قلت اسالك من تجربه لانه مرات بالتجارب
تؤكد هذه الجميله فيها فضول
قطعوا حلوين السنتين عليك كانت سنتين
على كل حال على سيره العادات بدنا نكمل
بهاي الاخبار فلا يهم ان كنت تصدق اللعنات
او لا سمعتي لا يهم ان كنت تصدقين لعنات
او لا او حتى تعتبريها افكارا في عالم ما
وراء الطبيعه في النهايه اصبحت قصصا
توارثتها الشعوب والاجيال ومن اشهرها
بخلاف لعنه الفراعنه الشهيره هناك لعبه
تيمور
زعامه الاساطير ان كل من يمس قبره بسوء
تلاحقه اللعنه شفتي كيف بحول اللعنات الى
فرح ولعبه وعندما فتحه علماء الاثار
السوفييت بامر من ستالين نفسه لنقل الى
موسكو بدل المانيا
بارباروسا الشهيره وتكبد الروس خلالها
خسائر هائله في عام 1973 الى لعنه اخرى
فتح فريق اثري مقبره الملك البولندي
كازيميرو الرابع بعدها مات بعض اعضاء
الفريق تباعا بعد فتره وجيزه ليكتشف
الخبراء اثار فطريات قاتله داخل المقبره
سببت
لعنه الماسه الامل ويقال انها حملت لعنه
تمثال الهندسيه يقال ايضا ان الصائغ
المجوهرات الفرنسيه اختلق هذه القصه لرفع
قيمتها لعنه مكبث وهي من خرافات في عالم
المسرح هي مرتبطه بالماساه التي حل
التاريخيا بانتاج المسرحيه ولعنه الماعز
مورفي في فريق شيكاغو تسمى ذلك نسبه لشخص
منع من دخول منعم من دخول ملعبه معه
ومعيزه مورفي وظل الفريق يخسر بطوله
متلاحقه